[Music]
welcome back to the sixth annual
Halloween special we are talking about
horror movies for the rest of October
and I've had various people on already
and I wanted to bring on a really good
friend of mine his name is Rob
how you doing Rob is an incredible actor
like you really you blew my mind when we
work together I'm serious
appreciate that I'm not saying that cuz
you're right here and because you're
very handsome we wanted to talk about
Evil Dead because I feel like both of us
have sort of like a personal affinity
for this movie in some way shape or form
oh yeah
I haven't actually asked you we want to
save it all for the video so like what's
been your experience with this film like
you know when you were younger and then
- now that was freaked out when I was
young I know wars I expected especially
with the lady trying to pound against
the like the bottom the basement
everything right and the makeup and all
that I was a little bit timid and scared
by watching it in the beginning so I
didn't I know what to expect I didn't
see when I was a kid either I never saw
it until I was older I think in fact I
think I saw Evil Dead 2 before I saw
this another movie
[Music]
you will get to as basically kind of a
remake of this it's kind of interesting
how it works yeah but like it was kind
of like he was like look we had fun
making this but let's try to make one
and just do it better it's called evil
that to put a production value right
what this movie feels like to me is two
guys in their backyard making a film and
they just did it yeah I got an idea
let's do it right Kevin in the woods
guy girl demons let's do it so if you
never seen Evil Dead which you should
it's basically some teenagers go to a
cabin and an old car that shows up in
every Sam Raimi movie by the way that
that you watch it's even in spider-man
and spider-man 2 is it it's Uncle Ben's
car in spider-man no that you just have
it like a conniption first pull up great
power yes yes
that's the car Wow he puts the car in
all of his movies alright and bruce
campbell in those of them too right so
they're pulling onto this cabin and
they're going there to be you know
teenagers or whatever yeah even though
they look like they're 25 well what is a
bad haircut oh my god the haircuts and
the wigs - the wigs so they're going to
this cabin and they stumble across all
this stuff in the basement there's this
old tape recording of somebody talking
about experiments he's discovered this
book that has the ability to raise the
dead yeah his wife has become infected
by this somehow and in a few quick shots
really without much exposition at all
stay for the tape you get everything you
need to know that was it yeah you got
the one guy walking through the basement
and he sees the weapons yeah he sees the
book everything the gun every single
thing that has to be in the film to
propel the plot along it's basically
shown to us within the first few minutes
yeah and then it's just action action
action action action action and quite a
bit of fucking blood out of Oh
[Applause]
I love the practical effects oh yeah in
the makeup I think for me the makeup in
the contacts or just to make up itself
and I was like trying to figure out like
Hara how are they seeing through it
because I can see like the contact
lenses but there's like on the from
wrong or not but I know there's a part
of the makeup where it's like just a
mask it did look like that yeah
especially when hurt is like like going
after him and stuff like that and then
the movements like that one move in when
she was in the bed his girl yeah when
that when she had a little wound and
then all of a sudden spread and then all
of a sudden came up like like that is a
board game when you're trying to sneak
it in the kitchen without waking daddy
Lana noise it could be back to bed for
you
[Music]
Parker Brothers I think one thing I like
the word just stick camera angles don't
mind I'm not like I'm not like a
filmmaker per se like I've dabbled into
it right now but the fact that it was
like one scene where whenever after a
girl got chopped all up and they buried
her it was like a simultaneous like I
don't know exactly I'd like to do some
research on this I don't know what type
of cameras he used but when I was
watching it I kept thinking to myself I
wish that I could put the camera in
these places then whatever he's doing
there's a shot of like an up angle shot
of Bruce Campbell standing and he like
moves his foot across the lens yeah and
I'm like I couldn't fit a red there like
unless you literally had him sustaining
a different spot took the ground out
from from one right put it over their
blood glass boxers yeah like that like
the camera above Bruce Campbell as he
walks and you see the ceiling boards
yeah yeah yeah all with the some effects
yeah
[Music]
well the sound effects to your Oregon
awesome let's talk about and then we
open up we watch this tonight and and I
heard you go away I heard you in the
background
every time it happened I'm big one sound
yeah I love the quiet place and I like
the way the Sun is so like sound is very
important to me in the movie so that the
fact that they kept playing the same
perfect cuz I was like the clip yeah and
then a hook I was like that's a
different sound there has to be a
different sounds I'm curious I wonder do
you think that Raimi did that purely
because low budget and not a lot of time
or because he thought it was funny cuz
there's definitely like a heart like a
kind of a edge for me for my outside
looking in I might say I might say he
just thought it was funny
I actually kind of think so yeah I mean
like there's tons of Doc's about this
movie and featurettes and he's not do
that sound anywhere blank and I've never
heard him say anything yeah no but like
that could be really why I mean there's
a lot of moments like that too that are
so fucking funny yeah
like a Campbell with like that big wood
beam just bash start a break trying to
break his like I'm gonna use a lesson
the little stuff and later like this
[Music]
there isn't like an ounce of
pretentiousness in this movie like they
were just literally making whatever I
wanted yeah this is our movie this is my
my dream yeah I'm gonna collaborate a
just good idea bad idea let's do it the
zombie woman's gonna be here and you're
just like punch her in the face it's
fine right even a slapper watches a
great angle goes with the slab great
angle okay you got me on two things I
have to say one I want to say the other
okay one the angles are just so creative
Kali oh yeah wherever he puts the camera
he utilizes this space this little tiny
space they have they have the woods the
car and the house and that's really it
but the other thing is Bruce Campbell's
physicality oh yeah he owns this move I
mean like throwing himself into
bookshelves downstairs fall on him
struggling you can tell these Russian
people right I mean he's in this friend
that's like he's all broken oh my granny
love dying like you're lessening his
lifespan right now how do I do this
it's your fault that he died they didn't
came round we actually murdered him with
white eye and then he tries to give him
a drink yeah sound will be up in an hour
so and we can all get out of here
together
oh I'll starting to count a little bit
cuz he started he had a little mini
monologue and he's like a giving him a
drink drinking it and then he was done
with it and he dropped it when he died
this is the kind of shit I love you know
yeah that's just so aware of itself and
gleefully just happy to seriously yeah
filmmaking I feel like all these kind of
filmmakers should not take them so
seriously because this is fun it looked
like they had fun
that's like they have
exactly movies like this despite its
technical problems yeah cuz there's tons
really it is if we talk about that down
there you know there's some shots super
out-of-focus
oh yeah but it's these types of movies
strangely that inspire me more than some
of those like perfectly directly right
right because it just you feel like the
passion coming through every single
frame exactly like they care about the
mistakes but they don't care about the
mistakes because they just wanted to
make the movie bring it out there
entertain the audience this blu-ray by
the way we watched it the new 4k
restoration and it's the best that's
ever looked still what does it call the
rori yeah yeah still had the same ratio
the still grainy of feel grainy fill and
everything I loved it
what do you think of the remake I've
never actually asked you that did you
see that 2013 I did I enjoy the remake
ugh it was dark but uh just feel like it
just took self too seriously
I agree I thought it was alright I I
enjoyed parts of it I think it suffered
from being overhyped remember that
poster the teaser poster that had it was
like the most terrifying movie I've ever
seen I was like that's it every poster
like that nowadays you just don't over
hype it so much yeah like don't make it
feel like it's gonna be the next coming
of Evil Dead Christ's version right or
whatever
yeah the remake was directed by a fede
alvarez he went on to do don't breathe
and he's doing the new Dragon Tattoo
movie next month so it looks good like
he's a talented he's talented iris and
don't breathe though what's that I
haven't seen don't oh shit it's good
don't need to see it's good man you
should see it as far as remakes go Evil
Dead the remake like some people hate it
some people love it
I'm middle the road on it I think it's
fine it for for like a serious non
satirical not funny Evil Dead movie they
did a pretty good job like you said the
makeups great but still like when I
watched this one on the original though
or Evil Dead 2 or even army of Darkness
there's just there's skeletons passion
you know that's just not there yeah
other films nowadays and one appreciate
whoa back to on on
the remake what I appreciate about that
is his vision at least sure he still had
a vision he would kind of went out
forward even though had some
similarities obviously since this is a
remake but for sure effect that he had a
vision and kind of went off for it I
gots to appreciate that oh of course
yeah as an artist oh of course yeah and
Sam Raimi historically has been super
supportive of filmmakers thank you he
always is trying to produce you know new
filmmakers get people to get their films
made he's Purdue go to his IMDB and look
up how many movies he's produced like
it's a lot that's that's humongous and
that's one of the reasons I love him you
know cuz he's so passionate about film
yes and it's an artist I was surprised
how much I loved it because it's been
years
ya know he can still laugh at those
little little bits and little comedy the
physical comedy like I told you earlier
like I love physical comedy anything
physical comment like the old school
like black and white films and stuff
like that but anyway with this one it's
a classic I'm curious for you
like as an actor as someone who works on
sets when you receive direction you know
like you're someone who appreciates and
understands how a film is made you
brought up that point about the makeup
covering their eyes yeah when you watch
a movie any movie or this one in
particular yeah are you doing that like
are you thinking like how did the actor
do that yeah scene cuz I'm always like
trying to study other actors and whatnot
because I love like you know the Meryl
Streep's the Viola Davis and Denzel
Washington and all those guys I try to
study them and try to figure out why
they made those choices and I think good
look at like no Bruce Campbell why he
made those choices even those little
little baby choices of him like the
standing against the door and like
looking around and trying to figure out
what's going on off sudden the girl came
out of nowhere in the back with those
with the dry wood yeah
those perfectly cut holes like with no
spinners I ask you that because as for
me I'm interested in directing and so
when I watch a movie I'm looking at the
way they put the camera and I've always
wanted to know how this someone has an
there yeah like are you looking at it
from the acting perspective I'm like
wondering how they those truck that's
that's fascinating yeah that's
fascinating to me
yeah that's great and also I'm trying to
look at it as a filmic and like a
filmmaking perspective as well just like
from a different perspective what I like
to make my own little things too
you know it's not the best quality but I
don't care I've like actually like this
is to do something yeah any kind of work
to support where you just said though i
yeah i guarantee that sam raimi looked
at this movie today and goes oh i would
have done so many different things yeah
you know but we we look at it and we're
like it's later you hear spielberg
that's fucking funny like spielberg many
times he said that there's very few of
his early films he wants to watch you
know like he'll watch Raiders and et
with his kids or whatever but like
doesn't like to watch jaws doesn't like
to look a lot of his movies because he
always is looking at the flaws which I
understand right you know like I totally
get that and so like you mentioned like
the stuff you want to make maybe you
don't have the budget yet to do what you
want to fuck it man right just do it I
just have fun that's what they did yeah
they just have fun and do it he used to
his family car his friend Bruce Campbell
yeah you know and some shitty cabin and
that's like an enduring clout yeah
that's how you start and then all of a
sudden you start making more of a films
or whatever alright Evil Dead 2 I've
always liked more like it's like we said
it's like the revamped version of this
but better but for a first time like
experience yeah the fact that this is
still sort of like the cabin in the
woods zombie experience most likely it's
incredible I love Evil Dead as far as
flaws it's like it's kind of hard to
like nitpick it because like you can
pinpoint little things like oh this
wouldn't have liked for instance when
the girl gets stabbed in the ankle I'm
like she would fall asleep right she'd
go to bed right you know they'd be
wrapped up yeah yeah and she would be up
you know there's little things like that
you could say you know like that was
kind of dumb or whatever but it's just
one of those things where the passion
and and just the pure ingenuity behind
them wanting to make this movie it sort
of just kind of blows
all away and these it's like whatever
mice just have fun yeah so I'm gonna
give the Evil Dead and a shoe I just go
ahead and give it a plus nice yeah yeah
I mean it's always enjoyed it I was like
yeah I think is gonna be a classic
forever I agree with you I think it's
was timeless movies well Rob thank you
so much they're telling me it was quite
I would love to have you on more videos
in the future you'd be interested in it
like I said Rob's an excellent actor if
you are an Ohio filmmaker or surrounding
state filmmaker or fuck it if you're
around the world and you're looking for
an actor
check out his demo reel he's a beast
thank you for sure that means a lot
thank ya for sure man all right guys
thank you so much as always for watching
we're gonna have more reviews for you
very soon some more horror films coming
out some new stuff some old stuff my
wife will be back in a few I got some
other friends to share with you guys
thanks so much for watching and if you
like this you can click right here and
get stuff my nice
[Music]